hey everybody welcome back to Jaeger
horn the topic of today's video is the
to lift Hills of the coaster as well as
the two first drops following these
which might seem like a little bit of a
trivial thing perhaps to dedicate hours
of work to but in hindsight I have to
say this is one of my favorite parts of
Jaeger horn by far and honestly one of
my favorite things I've ever done in
planet coaster and that is not to Pat
myself on the back too much it's
honestly something which kind of
happened throughout the project I never
really intentionally at one point the
thought of doing things this way but it
sort of happened as I worked on this
ride and sort of came together in this
way eventually so what I'm talking about
is we've got the two lifts Hills over
here which are set up as one of the most
important parts of the ride but honestly
I haven't really talked about it that
much so far so what I was going for here
is having to lift hills that kind of go
up a mountain in a sense that's kind of
similar to a funicular railway which is
an element which will come back into the
theming of these and I wanted to make
them interact as much as possible so the
first drop is the one that curves around
the other one and makes that sweeping
curve first underneath the lift Hill of
the other one and then going over a
little tunnel which the other one dives
under and the second drop is then the
the big one which is the largest and
most thrilling drop of the ride probably
and kind of almost the climax
near the end of the ride really so what
I like most about these things is that
during building the layouts it sort of
came together that these would interact
and be the sort of crossing points
because you also kind of noticed that
the first part of the ride really plays
around the church area and is kind of at
the front of the whole path Bulevar area
and then the second lift Hill is at the
same place but it goes in two completely
different direction and after the second
lift so you go into a whole different
parts of the park into a part which is
less more or less of a mountain and more
of just a slightly hilly section with
interaction with the queue and a lot of
trees so
the two halves of the ride are pretty
split and they're kind of different as
well in terms of speed and elements
where the first part is really having a
lot of curves and going at a pretty
moderate speed alongside the hillside
the second part of the ride really
starts off with this crazy dive into a
tunnel and after that a bunch of really
high speed airtime Hills in curves so
they're kind of different all around and
this part here is where they meet and
the one part where they have interaction
as well and this is something which you
can see already in the video it doesn't
happen every time I might need to adjust
the block brakes still a little bit but
if all goes well and if the dispatch
time matches up to what it should be
then both cars should arrive at the top
of the lift hill at exactly the same
time and then one car or train I should
say will spiral around the other ones
and I just really like the interaction
of the two trains because it means that
whatever train you're in you can always
see the other train arriving at the top
of the litter
at the same height at the same speed
right in front of you but in the other
direction
and then after that going down the first
drop you can either see the other train
spiraling around you or you can spiral
around the Train if you look to the
center of that curve you can see the
other train go down so I thought that
was some really cool interaction and
really one of my favorite parts of this
ride if not my very favorite part at
least when it comes to the coaster
experience itself and beside from that
interaction I wanted to make sure that
you can actually see this whole thing
happening from the path as well so
there's quite a bit of open path right
next to this and underneath the first
lift Hill and I'm trying to also theme
this in such a way that there is a
little bit of theming very similar to
the rest of the ride but most of the
foliage is kept quite low and I don't
add any obstacles from the view points
just to make sure that you have the view
as much as possible of the two trains
going down there drops at the same time
so yeah that's the sort of technical
explanation behind it and then when it
comes to the theming like I said I
wanted to keep this as low as possible
too
with some very close to the ground
shrubbery which also kind of is
reminiscent of having the shrubbery or
the trees and a very high altitude
because you typically get these very low
pine trees and a high altitude where as
pine trees are much taller at a lower
altitude so that actually kind of adds
to the theming as well if not the force
perspective and what I also wanted to do
is kind of dress up the lift Hills as
well as the first drops in a sense that
is kind of similar to a funicular
railway as well so the first lift Hill
will get this huge girder ayran
structure with lettuces and everything
to try and make this look as much as
possible to one of these old funicular
railways that go up mountain cliffs and
stuff like that and the second lift Hill
will be a little bit more simple since
it's mostly supported by the terrain but
also just get a similar overhaul to the
catwalks and if I remember correctly I'm
starting off here with the bridge just
wanted to build these two stone pillars
to make sure that there's something of a
foundation to connect the steel off the
bridge - and then shaping out the curve
of the bridge and then basically filling
in everything in between which is not as
hard as I expected it beforehand it is
actually pretty easy to try and make
these look as symmetrical as possible
you might be able to see some
similarities to regular bridges which
are just horizontal it's basically the
very same concept and a very similar
look to many regular bridges just placed
at an angle and honestly for inspiration
I just turned to Google Images and
looked up images of funicular railways
most of them aren't quite as fancy as
this is because of course they are
usually just a form of transport or some
kind of industrial thing or maybe
they're used for a ski resort so usually
there are a lot more minimalistic and
less fancy than this one but you know
because it's it's a theme park ride
anyway I wanted to try and dress this up
as much
as possible and kind of make it look
more like a Victorian brittle something
like that the only difficulty with all
of these things is that there is no very
small steel beams so I do have to use
these very small wooden beams in the
middle here but I hope that given the
context of everything around it being
steel and overall having the design of a
steel bridge I hope that it ends up
looking like a believable steel look
anyway now the rest of this detailing is
honestly just kind of guessing whatever
things should be like I'm honestly not a
structural engineer so I have no idea
what a bridge would actually have to be
like to be structurally sound so this is
just based on what bridges look like but
I think it's pretty much one point I
think it shouldn't collapse onto itself
I just I just love it when
rollercoasters go for unique support
structures if I can go on a bit of
attentions because after this I'm
getting into the catwalk and God knows
that now it was a bit of a annoying
thing to do and pretty time-consuming so
what you don't very often see is roller
coasters that theme their support
structures obviously it's something that
is quite difficult to do and it really
requires a kind of cooperation between
the coaster manufacturer and the park
and designers and really a lot of people
from different disciplines I supposed to
get a themed support structure but when
their use they're one of my favorite
elements on roller coasters I think
Baron 1898 is a very obvious example
that is definitely at least I think one
of the best-looking lift ales in the
world it has a little which doesn't use
the standard bnm supports but uses a
mineshaft like structure to emulate the
mine theme of the entire ride which is
really cool
I know alpengeist in Busch Gardens
Williamsburg has ski lifts like supports
I'm not entirely sure how much they look
like an actual ski lift but it's still a
really fun touch to the coaster and
there are many very similar cases of
roller coasters having unique support
structures I think the roller coaster
that is most comparable to this one is
probably Expedition Everest in Disney
which
a very similar catwalk running up a
mountain as the coaster goes up the
mountain a difference is that over there
the coaster actually goes into a tunnel
at the end of the bridge but it's it's
still very similar and it also looks
very much like a funicular railway I
think so yeah I love those support
structures definitely one of my favorite
touches on rollercoasters whenever
they're possible but obviously they're
quite limited when it comes to the theme
because you have to incorporate it into
the theme in some way and alpengeist
having an Alpine theme and Baron 1898
having a mine theme stuff like that
definitely works out but it only works
out in very very specific cases like
that but I thought in Jaeger horn it was
a very good opportunity to do it as well
so yeah there it goes now for the rest
of these catwalks I wanted to slightly
change them a little bit because this is
just a little bit of a pet peeve of mine
but I wanted to do something about it
anyway one thing which I kind of dislike
about catwalks or supports or anything
that you're given from a game itself
that you don't have to build yourself is
that even though they might look good
like the catwalks and supports in planet
coaster look great they are always the
same
so whoever built a coaster always get
the same looking catwalks in the same
looking supports and that is something
that just perks me slightly because
after years of playing this game and
after having seen so many different
creations from different people you know
no matter how creative certain things
are you always notice the same catwalks
you always noticed that they have the
same texture the same look and
everything so in this case I wanted to
just use that catwalk as a bit of a skin
to put my own theme on and put a bit of
a thematic spin on it as well so I'm
trying to make this metallic standard
default catwalk look like a wooden
catwalk which would be more in place on
a mine train coaster but the
disadvantage of doing that I suppose is
that you have to replace every single
step on the thing with a small wooden
stand
and you have to replace all the railings
on the exact angles etc with the wooden
ones but I think in the end it's it's
kind of worth it
I like the slightly changed look even if
from the coaster itself you don't notice
it that much these are just the details
that you know if I didn't change them
they would kind of stick out to me at
the end and because of that I just
wanted to add this too it doesn't mean
that I would do this on every single one
of my coasters and it definitely doesn't
mean that it's something I dislike about
a coaster if it doesn't have a unique
catwalk but I think in case of a mine
train like this where every structural
elements of the coaster kind of becomes
part of the theming it's something that
I definitely wanted to change in
hindsight though when I did this first
stair I quickly realized that I could
have just built a few steps and then
just copy-paste that those all over the
place so I'll definitely keep in mind to
do that with the second staircase as
you'll see and the rest of this is
really just trying to support this thing
in a way that would visually make sense
although I do have to say there will
definitely have to be some steel beams
hidden underneath this structure because
I don't think a coaster would be
approved by safety whatever whatever
kind of institution goes on safety
rollercoasters I don't think that
institution would be okay with the
coaster being supported by a few wooden
beams so there is probably some kind of
hidden actual structure underneath all
of that and for the second catwalk I
wanted to try a very similar design but
just with a few small differences using
different wooden posts and stuff like
that I do want to apologize for moving
the camera so much during these time
lapses honestly what I always try to do
is minimize the amounts then I move the
camera around in these because as much
as it helps in gameplay some of your
camera around and see everything from
different angles when you speed up
gameplay twelve times it really becomes
kind of unwatchable sometimes and
usually I try to think about it as much
as I can and try to move the camera as
little as I can
but in this case there's just so many
little details and so much stuff that
you can't just copy-paste around that I
couldn't really help but have to move
the camera all the time in the next
episode though which I am currently in
the process of recording I am building a
few buildings and really just focusing
on their facades so I'll be moving the
camera around as little as possible
which so far has actually been going
really great it's something I've always
tried to kept and keep in mind but never
really took to the max to try and blend
my building ahead in such a way to move
the camera as little as possible but
that's something which I might want to
try a little bit more because the way
that I've always looked at these videos
is like these time-lapse videos are just
sort of more of a byproduct of doing
this stuff because I would have been
building it anyway but in this case I
can make some videos out of it which is
great for everyone but by now these
videos often get more views than the
actual final videos of these projects so
I might as well focus on these videos as
their own thing and not just a byproduct
of some end product that I'm working
toward so maybe I'll think about those
kind of building ways a little bit more
in the future
but for these bridges it was honestly
kind of difficult because they're kind
of large kind of all over the place
and really I have to pay attention to
the most my new details to try and cover
up all of these little steel parts and
things that I want to make invisible as
much as possible so yeah that was
actually offered the catwalks and that
whole area over there but then I
realized there was still this bridge
which was so far kind of floating and
one of the problems that I had with this
bridge honestly is that it seemed
unsupportable because the way that it's
built is really giving myself a hard
time it was kind of stupid to do this in
the first place because you'll notice
that all of the other bridges they have
unbanked track and the track doesn't
move up or down maybe there's a slight
angle in the bridge or it's quite steep
actually but there's no difference in
steepness in most of the other bridges
but this one is just kind of annoying
because it goes from going up to going
down
was a bit of an arch in it and it also
goes from banking to the left to banking
to the right so it's really got damn
annoying bridge to support and that's
why I kind of didn't want to do it for
the longest time but at this point I
really figured you know I need to stop
procrastinating I didn't want to end the
episode at 14 minutes something so I
decided to build this thing as well and
add something to this surrounding area
and in the end what actually kind of
helped was to just build the wooden
planks according to the to the curvature
of the track I suppose try to just make
sure that they all connect to all of the
track pieces and then just kind of go
from there which didn't even turn out to
be that hard I just copy the curve from
one side over to the other and even if
the whole thing looks a little bit
strange I think this is just about the
only thing that I could do and at least
by combining all of these planks
together
it is a strangely curved bridge that
could theoretically actually be built in
real life as well so that's a problem
out of the way and I believe also that
with this bridge built all of the
bridges in the park are finished and
there's not much to worry about anymore
when it comes to that wrong with that no
I think that's it
there's just a lot of foliage and a lot
of work work to still do so I'm also
trying to chip away at the foliage and
rock work in every episode that I can as
well now here's a little bit of fun
detailing which I already did with some
of the lampposts and some my earlier
stuff but I don't do all the time
because it's something which takes way
too many faces and way too many time for
how much of a detail it really is but I
thought for this bridge you can actually
kind of work out and that's adding nails
to all of the logs so yeah it's not
something that you notice too much but
it definitely you know when you look at
the whole thing as a whole it even if
it's tan it doesn't stand out it makes
the bridge look a little bit more
realistic and I could insert the nails
here so I figured I might as well now
the final bit here is me trying to do
the foliage in such a way that I can
cover up what's backstage because
honestly the end of the park or at least
the end of the the
public part of the park and the border
between the park and the backstage areas
is just a few meters away from the path
here and I do wanna cover that up but at
the same time I do wanna make sure that
these these two drops are still open for
the view as much as possible so there's
a little bit of a transition from low
foliage to very tall foliage and some
other final details like the lamppost
over there
all of the lampposts on the catwalk
itself I honestly haven't checked at
nighttime yet and I'm definitely gonna
have to line up these bridges a little
bit more than they currently are but I
am pretty confident that these bridges
will look pretty swell at night and I
think these lamps do add a bit more of a
mind train touch to the right again
especially because there are these
really small oil lamps which I suppose
you could either just place on crates or
uses some kind of clutter or something
like that but I actually really like
putting these things on small posts
because they're one of the smaller cuter
lamp designs in the game and it just
looks quite simple and that's more or
less the look I'm going for here and the
final parts of this video should be
making this little jump from one walk to
the other most of this little unlike the
other one is supported by the
terraforming and it's really just
covering the ground at all points but
this is little space where it goes down
a bit which is partly because there's
the curve right underneath there and I
didn't want to make too much of a steep
steep cliff face because I felt like
that would look really unnatural like
there is no way that a natural mountain
terrain would be perfectly 45 degrees
and perfectly support this whole catwalk
so I wanted to make that a little bit
more random and at the same time it gave
me the opportunity to work on these
small terrain rail supports looking
things I honestly have no idea what to
call these things but sometimes when you
have a train rail that's built a few
meters of the ground you have these very
typical wooden support beams underneath
it so that's really what these things
are here for I think it adds a bit more
to the atmosphere and that's basically
it for this video so thank you guys for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed this
video as much as I did and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]